every Tuesday up high on money series
looks at financial issues Americans are
facing this morning a new bank rate
survey says 76% of Americans have at
least one financial regret only one
among those people more than half are
disappointed with their savings CBS News
business analyst Jill Schlesinger is
here with some tips on how to save for
retirement y'all good morning morning
there's also a Federal Reserve survey
that shows alarmingly that a quarter of
Americans have no retirement savings
yeah and it's really interesting because
with all these surveys that we have an
annual report that comes out from a body
that looks at this huge amount of
Americans and say how do you feel about
retirement are you confident and
according to the survey results about
two-thirds of Americans say I am totally
confident and eighty-two percent say
yeah I'm feeling good about this and you
put that into the lens of the savings
amount we also find out that only 42
percent of Americans have actually run
their own retirement numbers so they
feel confident I'm not exactly sure why
they feel so confident just because
because the economy is better because
jobs are more plentiful because they're
getting wage increases but we really
need people to focus on this because you
are going to be responsible for your own
retirement people who now think you know
I'm never gonna retire they're gonna
cart me out of the place this is a
little bit of wishful thinking because
you're absolutely right about 80 percent
say hey don't worry about me not having
retirement savings because I'll just
work longer that's great as long as you
can keep your job and as long as you can
physically do your job and what we find
out is only about 28% of people are
working after retirement so we've got to
go back to what should I do
now what should I do now right starting
at 20s oh I'd like to know what how it
should work at everything sooner okay
Millennials will look at the - like the
youngest Millennials we say pay off that
debt credit card auto loan student loan
debt really focus on that maybe try
don't save well there may be five to six
percent that's what you're gonna try to
do older Millennials try to save more
like 10 to 15 percent and really focus
on that when you look at Gen Xers these
the next group of people now your debts
are paid off
now you're really chugging away at
retirement now what we want people to do
is put in 15% maybe 20% of your earnings
into retirement again to the best of
your ability the federal limit is
$19,000 I know a lot of people are not
going to do that but we got to try and a
lot of people who are boomers are sorry
Gen Xers are saying I want to pay down
my mortgage don't pay down your mortgage
save for retirement first then comes the
mortgage and finally that for for those
people who are nearing retirement we
look at those baby boomers run your
numbers there is a great calculator it's
called the EBR I choose to save
calculator it is amazing run those
numbers see where you stand and then
what I say is do a Goldilocks scenario
don't have too much risk in your say in
your portfolio but don't have too little
risk and be sure to go to SSA gov and be
familiar with your retirement benefits
through Social Security okay run the
number one sorry
thank you